i have pleasured myself with meat and
vegetables does the owner of that
secret revelation want to come forward
right now
nobody coming in no are you building
drama is this yours
i guess i'll have to own up to it
let's hear your revelation what is this
meat and vegetables thing that you've
done
and what kind of meat did you use a
salami
this sounds like robin during her barren
years i've never had a child
when you weren't dating anybody i was a
young girl how young
in my late teens early 20s all right you
were experimenting
not experimenting at all i would wake up
in the middle of the night
so horny by the way let me say something
about you
that you've admitted on the air that
you're so orgasmic
that literally you could sit on your
foot like just put your foot tuck your
foot under your ass
and you will come yeah i can come in
many ways right but
this at the time i was very young and i
didn't know
a lot of different ways how young did
you say you were 19
19 20 right and it would wake me up in
the middle of the night
that you were horny yes and i was at i
lived at home
and i was just like oh my god i'd be
on fire this is during your time of
college right yeah right
and i was just like oh my god what am i
going to do i have to relieve this
somehow and there were no such thing you
know there were no dildos
or vibrators hanging around why did you
not put this in your book
because you because it embarrasses me i
mean i was like a rabid dog
rooting around the house for vegetables
maybe
anything maybe this explains why look at
bottles
you know i just didn't find anything
that was the right shape inside
where's the goddamn plunger maybe maybe
this one you know
you consider oh that might splinter you
you look at
everything and then finally you go oh my
god
i'm in the refrigerator i'm in the
vegetable bin
and there's this huge cucumber and i'm
like well it's waxy
right so you go and you try to use that
that's too big
finally you go to the
freezer and you're like all right pickle
you try the hot dogs
and you use the hot dog well they were
not big enough
because it was it could have broken off
inside of you a frozen hot dog
you can't use it frozen either that
doesn't work you have to then thought
this is how intense it was you go
through
all of this stuff so what did you use
for me i finally found some nice
sausages now let me ask you a question
when you raid your mom's refrigerator
and you find
sausage yes when you're done with it do
you put it back so she won't know
no but then you have to figure out a way
to discard it so nobody will find just
wasted food sauce so all i mean there
were it was like a salad and a meal
you know there was sausage there were
vegetables and so it all had to be like
gotten rid of how many times did this
happen uh i would say
five or six but then you you know how
you talk about you know after you
pleasure yourself you're disgusted with
yourself this was really disgusting you
were just like oh what kind of one you
guys what the hell is wrong with you
what kind of woman am i what about what
kind of human being what was your
favorite thing to use during all of this
none of it was favorite because like i
said it was very disgusting right
and you know it was you know finally
finding a guy was the best
that was the kind of sausage you needed